hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer today
i'm making a dish without any trash i
don't know why it's the dish yet it's
gonna be a surprise and i don't like
surprise
you know in a daily life when you're
cooking you're making a lot of trash
without noticing
in the kitchen i use a lot of saran
wraps plastic containers i feel like i
should be more conscious about it we
make a lot of trash and where does it go
perrier there's a folder underneath what
you're making will be revealed inside
what's this
apple pie apple has cords and stem so
apple pie we will need flour butter
apples cinnamon powder and sugar most of
the dry ingredients come in a package so
i hope we can find a grocery store that
has box section so i can bring my own
containers
because they look like potato it's the
potato pie
so this was my first time going to the
grocery store with bulk section brown
sugar
i don't see brown sugar what are we
gonna do i think i'm gonna use more
granulated sugar brown sugar has more
flavor but this challenge is not make
the best apple pie this challenge is no
waste
i assume this comes in a box with a
wrapper inside you know so i'm going to
go with this
so it's less trash that's trash is still
trash
trust trash
and we got a little bit cinnamon in a
giant jar i've got granny smith's apples
since we are doing no trash i want to
choose organic so i can use peel it had
stick on it so sad i just remembered i
made this beautiful rose apple pie for
tasty
and i can use apple skin that's kind of
bummer because i chose green apple i
should have chose red apple that's why i
don't like surprises
i'm still figuring out how to use core
maybe i'm gonna just
eat them i'll sacrifice myself for this
challenge
making pie
now we're gonna make a pie crust right
quarter cup of sugar two and a quarter
cup of flour
and now butter you want to use cold
butter and cut into a small pieces this
is a butter with least amount of trash
we could find trash in a bowl okay i'm
gonna use this ball scraper to make
butter small pieces
okay now i'm adding ice water in a pie
dough
i love making pie
something like very calming about it my
pie dough is almost done
and usually you have to wrap with saran
wrap saran wrap is also a waste so i
think if i have a container with lid
it's going to totally do the job
i'm gonna wash my hands
eating the stickers
it's kind of sad
after that i'm gonna wash this apple and
slice them thinly
[Music]
struggles i'm gonna make a separate
waist like food waste and trash
but you know the taste will be good it's
very tight this apple is very slippery
the rosa papaya made was without peel so
what if it doesn't work
i'm going to
macerate with sugar half cup of sugar
half cup of brown sugar but we don't
have it
cinnamon
okay and leave this another 30 minutes
so it's gonna get soft
all right so my pie dough is chilled for
30 minutes and i'm going to
roll out this dough sprinkle flower on
the surface
i think it's a good side
so i'm going to
prick
do you see a prick break the dough so it
doesn't puffed up we have this apple
macerated
[Music]
i have leftover juice and i'm going to
boil it down make a syrup and i can top
with it
it's not that much
and i'm going to grab a spatula
oh no
i bet
burnt oh okay
no waste
okay so i have a leftover though what
kind of pattern should i make like leaf
maybe
usually you stick with egg wash you know
if i use egg there will be eggshell egg
garden
so i'm gonna just put water and hope for
the best i feel pretty good about the
amount of waste i made i don't want to
speak too soon so i have some left over
though what about if i make pie
hi
i use all dough yay
so i got this
silicone mat you can use as a parchment
paper hi
so i'm gonna go bake in the oven
bye
[Music]
40 minutes
[Music]
tada
pie
i think i did great it was hard but it's
totally durable when i started i was 50
confident but i made this beautiful pie
and i'm pretty feel good about it both
my pies and amount of trash i created i
think we should be more conscious about
how much trash we are making in daily
life if you are more conscious about
what to choose you can totally make less
waste so i'm going to share this with my
coworkers and let's see what they think
wow those look like sausages
it looks pretty i had to make this pie
without making any waste and this is the
amount of trash i
created
[Music]
i can compost the core after i eat it
now do we eat yeah please
stop time
also doesn't it taste better knowing
that hardly any trash was created i'm
actually really impressed because i have
not tried to make something this
ambitious but you've inspired me this is
so good simple
tasty delicious
tasty moisture
nothing else to say
tasty no waste
[Music]
you